bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique l'émission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation la course à la vitesse
fait rage dans l'internet il ne suffit
pas de proposer des contenus encore
faut-il que les usagers y est facilement
et surtout rapidement accès je parle ici
de la technologie des cdn pour content
delivery network soit en bon français
les réseaux de diffusion de contenu dans
ce domaine les européens sont en retard
mais les français réagissent orange
annonce à partenariat avec ge et corlab
une société installée au luxembourg pour
en parler je reçois jérôme barré
directeur général services aux
opérateurs et réseaux internationaux
chez orange bonjour jérôme barré bonjour
aller votre définition rapide de ce
qu'est un cdn d'un cdn c'est un ensemble
d'équipements on gagne le logiciel qu'on
met en réseau et qui comme vous le
disiez permettre de gérer et distribuer
les contenus
ça peut paraître mystérieux mais chaque
fois vous allez consulter une page
internet regarder un film va vous
utilisez services par exemple moi je
suis france 24 j'ai envie que mes mais
mes auditeurs puissent voir ce que je
dis sur france 24 points comme et donc
j'ai besoin d'un cdn tech a au mali aux
états unis on puisse serait exactement
chaque fois que vous avez encore du
podcastable ou même un contenu groupe
diffusés en live sur le web vous avez
besoin d'un cdn alors qui sont les
grands acteurs alors les grands acteurs
aujourd'hui ce sont des grands groupes
américains très grand coup babacar au
premier rang desquels akamai un cas
représente 50% de la part de marché
mondiale par ninon 1 et puis des chinois
et que vous visiez et comme vous le
disiez pad européen 1 pourquoi pas parce
que l'a pas vu passer le train oui un
peu parce que c'est un petit peu à
l'image de ce qui s'est passé sur le sur
le net avec l'arrivée des grands géants
américains et finalement les cdn ont
suivi le mouvement et alors les gars
femmes à les géants américains ils sont
dessus aussi où il laisse à karaj
tranquille alors il faut deux choses
parce que lille on s'est suffisamment
stratégique pour eux pour qu'ils aient
leur propre service rezéenne et puis
c'est aussi clients parce que generali
sens que l'appel multisource et
plusieurs fournisseurs ils sont aussi
clients des grands fournisseurs du cdn
et vous orange une multinationale nous
la téléphonie les réseaux vous aviez
besoin d'un cdn d'abord ce qu'il faut
bien avoir en tête c'est que vous avez
deux mondes le monde des internautes est
ce que vous savez combien d'internautes
dans le monde aujourd'hui enfin je
suppose qu'on a largement dépassé 10
milliards 4,6 la rivière et ça augmente
d'un milliard tous les trois ans ah oui
et c'est pas fini parce que la fracture
numérique
malheureusement il existe encore et on
veut plus en plus que tout le monde
puisse avoir accès à l'internet en
particulier en afrique orange open
grotte opérateurs africa est connu et
donc ça va continuer il est le
confinement ont montré qu'on avait
besoin aussi et puis de l'autre vous
avez des dots de l'autre vous avez des
fournisseurs d'accès internet des
fournisseurs de contenus pardon qui sont
les grands que vous collectez les
netflix les disney les google et
facebook l'amazone et inra et puis aussi
beaucoup d'autres tous les plus petits
des régionaux et puis toutes les chaînes
de télévision comme nous que vous avez
vous et puis ces deux mondes les 4,7
milliards d'internautes et ses grands
fournisseurs de contenus ils veulent
communiquer avec celle de l'internaute
d'accéder au plus grand nombre de
contenus possibles rapidement et
rapidement et les fournisseurs de
contenus veut layton leur audience et je
pense que faisait 1 4 point sur des
tables sur l'audience et donc tout ça ça
crée un besoin de communication énorme
et c'est là que vous intervenez aroui
parce que ce besoin c'est au fossat
l'internet mondial ouais c'est
l'internet mondial et là encore quand on
regarde de l'augmentation de ce trafic
sur l'internet mondial on est sur des
chiffres de plus 30% par an ça veut dire
que sa double tous les trois ans donc
donc un besoin énorme de connexion et
donc aussi de l'augmentation de la
taille des réseaux pour pouvoir
mettre en relation ces fournisseurs de
contenu et ses internautes pour bien
comprendre les cdn c'est du logiciel oui
alors peut-être qu'il faut rentrer un
tout petit mieux dans la façon dont ça
fonctionne d'abord on est sur des
logiques mondialisée plein le monde max
et d'amérique c'est donc donc forcément
cette mise en relation elle est mondiale
alors les mecs vous allez regarder un
film et flix vous n'allez pas toujours
aller sur un serveur américain
ouais heureusement audouy le serveur
doit être proche de moi voilà ça veut
dire que doc les gros fournisseurs de
contenus s'organise avec des serveurs
qui seraient partis un peu partout dans
le globe avec à ses datacenter et reliés
entre eux par des câbles de plus en plus
des caps ona qui permette que tous les
serveurs sur le niveau d'information
donc ça c'est l'environnement classique
et puis ça suffit pas parce que vous
avez besoin même si beaucoup de data
center de vous rapprocher de
l'utilisateur final et la technologie
évolue vers ce qu'on appelle des caches
savez sur votre micro se repaissaient
sur votre smartphone vous avez du cash
il stocke l'information que vous accédez
à laquelle vous accédez le plus
rapidement sur les réseaux c'est pareil
des espèces de buffer sur le réseau qui
stocke les informations les pages web
les films que vous regardez le plus
souvent et le cdn bas c'est un ensemble
de réseaux d'équipements de réseaux et
de logiciel qui gère héberge organise
cette distribution des contenus et qui
vous permette comme un utilisateur final
d'accéder aux vos contenus et de savoir
où aller pour y accéder jusqu'à présent
vous préviens partenaires s'étaient
akamai que vous avez toujours oui alors
bien sûr alors ce qu'il faut bien avoir
en tête c'est que orange et c'est moins
connu peut-être que nos activités grand
public ali orange est un grand carrière
internationale ça veut dire que nous
sommes un des principaux leaders de
l'interconnexion entre tous les acteurs
du monde de télécommunications donc tous
les opérateurs de télécommunications et
les opérateurs télécommunications avec
les fournisseurs d'accès donc on relit
c'est à dire le fait pas c'est
finalement les informations les
giga octets d'information qui passe sur
les réseaux mais plus en plus la valeur
monte sur cette couche d'optimisation
des contenus et donc notre ambition
c'était effectivement d'être présent là
dessus donc vous passez par akamai alors
présent on avait on a un partenariat
avec akamai ou non et donc bah on
voulait on voulait aller on veut se
développer alors pourquoi on se
développer ça marchait qui représente 8
milliards 8 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires 1 mondiale avec une
croissance de 20% par an au monde a pour
cent par année et on se dit que en plus
de notre rôle historique de carrière il
ya une place à prendre parce que
opérateurs américains de cdn opérateurs
chinois on se dit qu'il ya place pour un
même trajet en revers et à 20k un
africain dans un monde ali où la
souveraineté et la confiance ont de plus
en plus d'importance parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on manipule quand on manipule ces
informations c'est l'audience c'est ce
que vous consultez ce que je consulte ce
qu'on nous ce qui nous regarde consul
vaut mieux avoir la main dessus vous dit
eh ben voilà il y en a des acteurs si
vous voulez on a on a vendu une
prestation de saisine de cdn a tous
senti que reed et on a des acteurs qui
demandent de plus en plus à ce qui est
des informations qu'ils soient gérés et
hébergés localement en orange en afrique
protéger et donc on avait besoin au-delà
la canaille de chômeurs européens
européen avant que city ce partenaire
alors qu'on a on a noué un partenariat
avec avec cet acteur que j'ai le corps
labs qui est un acteur émergent européen
basé au luxembourg qui va nous apporter
deux choses que l'on apporté des
technologies notamment des outils de
logiciels software et puis aussi de
l'interconnexion avec beaucoup
d'opérateurs parce que ce qui compte
dans ce monde là pour faire de la mise
en relation ses droits de l'audience me
mets donc ayant de la terre relation
d'interconnexion avec beaucoup
d'opérateurs internet dans le monde et
particulièrement en europe pour nous
cette cet opérateur cette entité cette
entreprise et colas vous apporte à la
fois cette technologie et cette part de
marché
aujourd'hui ils ont quelques % de parts
de marché dans le monde d'accord c'est
encore en fait c'est un marché qui est
très très morcelé à cabaye pèse très
lourd pas loin de 50 % du marché mondial
et après vous avez vous avez une myriade
d'acteurs quelques gros acte
relativement gros acteurs américains et
après un marché qui est très éclaté on
menace marches éclatées notre ambition
orange c'est de prendre une position de
leader en europe et en afrique là où sur
nos marchés historiques marché un grand
public et entreprise et en proposant une
offre est une offre souveraine qui va
proposer à nos clients d'avoir une
solution une solution de proximité
avec de l'hébergement garantie qui va
apporter la réponse à leurs besoins
leader en europe et en afrique c'est à
dire que vous allez prendre des parts de
marché à akamai par exemple ça veut dire
qu'on va prendre des parts de marché ça
veut dire qu'on va accompagner aussi là
on va prendre des parts de marché mais
n'oubliez pas que ç'a marché qui croît
de 1 % par an oui oui
tout à fait donc c'est pas que de la
part de marché et salées captées à les
capter le potentiel
et puis oui vous avez il avait beaucoup
de téléspectateurs qui nous écoutent en
afrique on voit qu'on a beaucoup de
fournisseurs de contenus africains qui
ne rêve que d'une chose c'est d'étendre
leur présence en afrique vous avez des
diffuseurs européens qui veulent aussi
d'étendre leur présence mais c'est aussi
cela que vous prenez j'ai quand la psy
vous l'amener en afrique avec vous c'est
en amènera on utilisera gekkan labs on
va utiliser les technologies cloud en
europe en afrique on va utiliser ce
partenariat pour effectivement proposer
des solutions à tous les diffuseurs de
contenus qui veulent étendre leur
présence leur diffusion sur le continent
européen sur le continent africain ça
peut aller plus loin qu'un partenariat
pour l'instant il ya
est-ce que c'est la technologie 2g
corlab vous intéresse et ce que oui
s'intéresse aussi à améliorer cette
techno un oui oui parce que si vous
voulez vous nous veut on veut combiner
de force la force d'un réseau un réseau
d'orange présent partout avec des points
de présence partout nous avons des
câbles sous marins nous avons des
réseaux terrestres nous avons deux
satellites nous avons des ce qu'on
appelle des points de présence on
permettent de raccorder les clients
nos partenaires nous apportent du
software de la technologie et on va être
synergique un plus ça va faire trois et
l'objectif c'est effectivement coco
développe notre présence et qu'on
devienne qu'on devienne un leader dans
un monde
ali où on veut aussi rééquilibrer notre
rapport de force avec les grands
fournisseurs justement vers dernières
questions réponses rapides votre marché
la cible on a compris c'est l'europe et
l'afrique c'est tous voulaient pas
sortir de ça leur ont l'europe et
l'afrique mais c'est plutôt
effectivement
les opérateurs fin des fournisseurs de
contenus européen africain mais qu'on va
aussi accompagner le reste du monde
d'accord comme aider c'est aussi
permettre que va pas s'arrêter à nos
frontières
merci beaucoup jérôme barré pour vos
réponses l'entretien de l'intelligence
économique est terminée vous pouvez
évidemment ont trouvé cette émission sur
france 24 points comme sur nos réseaux
sociaux et sur nos podcasts au revoir
[Musique]